foreign
by the time my father had died the war
between the North and the South which
had been so long threatened had broken
out and the Gunplay was on quite all of
the able-bodied men capable of bearing
arms throughout the country were
enthusiastically enlisting in some of
the many military organizations that
were being formed and going from their
homes into military encampments although
completely captivated by the glowing
reports of the excitement I ignored my
boyish inclinations and declined to join
the Army I could not see how mother and
the children could possibly support
themselves without my assistance who was
the oldest of the flock and now quite
useful as a bread owner I therefore held
back quite a while longer but in some
quarters it was said here is Walsh
Grayson who's a well-educated young man
capable of making a useful soldier in
the Army as a commissioned officer or
otherwise and Yeti declines to join the
Army he should be made to take his place
in one of the companies and do Duty as
others are doing
this kind of talk besides occasional
innuendos derogatory to my personal
courage in case of a conflict of arms
determined me to enter the field and
show my critics if occasion offered the
stuff I Was Made of even if it cost me
my life to make the exhibition
[Music]
that is how Civil War infantry will wake
up in the mornings usually at 5am there
are better ways and morning Brew the
free daily newsletter that gives you the
news in an easy to digest form is a
great choice and our sponsor for this
video before morning Brew I would start
my day by aimlessly surfing the internet
filling my head with click bait and
existential dread for an hour morning
Brew on the other hand gets me up to
speed on business finance and Tech in
just five minutes in a witty and
engaging way it's quick and easy and
condensed down in a digestible form it's
a great and fast method to start the day
knowing more it's kept me up to date
with all of SpaceX and Elon musk's
latest Shenanigans as well as simply and
easily giving me all the latest details
on geopolitics worldwide and also this
banana peeling robot and the best thing
is that it is free so there's basically
no reason not to subscribe to morning
Brew if you're interested in business
finance or Tech it takes less than 15
seconds to subscribe head over to
morningbrewdaily.com forward slash votp
to try it out now thanks to morning Brew
for supporting history content on
YouTube
how long I served as a private Soldier I
do not know but the need of my services
especially in view of my supposed
Superior education and fitness and
ability in the conduct of the Affairs of
our company was pressing having in years
not attained my majority I was a mere
boy and by far the youngest Captain
serving in the Indian Brigade the first
time that I with my company came
anywhere near taking part in a scrap
With the Enemy as I now recall was at
the Battle of Honey Springs some two or
three miles north of the present town of
jakota we'd been encamped in the
vicinity of the springs for some weeks
when the enemy under General blunt came
out of Fort Gibson to see what we were
doing and incidentally to feel our pulse
if advisable with my own men and a
pickled body of others from the second
Creek regiment without Colonel chili
Macintosh in immediate command we were
ordered to occupy a certain position in
the dense bottom of the creek here we
remained listening breathlessly at the
rattle of small arms and an occasional
exalting whoop that was one of the
characteristics of the fighters of the
Southern forces and anxious to take a
hand in the affray but could do nothing
without orders by what I have always
confidently believed to be bad
management we lost the day here when the
enemy came up and engaged us for our
general Cooper did not even get all his
men out on the firing line or into any
engagement with his adversary before he
ordered his forces to retire
although on this occasion I remember
hearing delivered by our colonel in
Indian the finest War speech I ever
heard
when you first saw the light it was said
of you a man-child is born you must
prove today whether or not this saying
of you was true the Sun that hangs over
our heads has no death no end of days it
will continue indefinitely to rise and
to set but with you it is different man
must die sometime and since he must die
he can find no nobler death than that
which overtakes him while fighting for
his home his fires and his country
[Music]
The Retreat left the family's resident
in the country without any protection
and as the enemy was destroying
everything in the way of their March it
was important that each family and
non-combatant decide and quickly whether
to remain at home and Trust the mercy of
the invading enemy or load up such few
things as they were compelled to have
into wagons and as our forces were doing
following Retreat towards the Choctaw
Nation
in general our soldiers were poorly clad
and most of the time my company
presented a Motley appearance the
Confederacy being hard run had very
little in the way of clothing to issue
to the man on the part of the country
and we were never very presentable so
when we called a prisoner from the other
side we generally stripped him clean of
his wearing apparel as we desired they
being always better than our own and
placed upon him instead such as our own
old Duds as he could wear how government
had issued our men certain wool hats
which appeared to be manufactured of the
plain sheep's wool without any coloring
while the hatter seemed not to have
seriously concerned themselves about the
Symmetry and Poise of any of any
individual hat
one such hat that it well nice served
its time and collected its full share of
dust and discolorations was owned and
worn by machanelli being a young man of
decided the Indian taste in matters of
dress and orientation he embellished it
in true Aboriginal Style with one of the
plumes of the wing of the falcon
commonly known in the country as the
chicken hawk the shaft of which had been
carefully paired away and rendered so
thin pliant and limber that the least
air disturbance gave it a vibratory or
rather tremulous motion highly
responsive to the Indian's idea of
Aesthetics
this feather he'd securely fastened in
the Apex of his hat where it had for
considerable time done service doubtless
to the admiration of his comrades in war
[Music]
as we were riding along discussing the
situation we reached a small Choctaw
Farm of probably not over 10 acres an
extent on our right planted in corn as
we rode silently along I observed ahead
of us horses which appeared to be tied
to the fence we saw at first no Riders
although the horses were saddled and
bridled we halted and listened for the
sound of voices but heard none we then
stealthily crept nearer where we saw I
think two men lying near up to the fence
fast asleep my blonde friend seemed to
think that this was our time to get in
our work on the enemy and suggested that
we rush upon them and dispatch them
while they slept he'd already impressed
me as being not very practical in some
of his ideas and Views and fearing he
might be dependent on the certain
operation of his little old pistol which
might fail to work when we reached the
dispatching moment and cause us to be
killed or taken prisoners I asked to
examine the gun at a glance I became
satisfied that there was great danger it
would not fire at all and a y eyes view
of the situation manifestly dictated
that we go slow in the proposed work of
death but we had no clubs at hand with
which we might Club them to death and I
was not sure that my blonde friend and I
were able to pounce upon these men and
choke them to death I counseled that we
leave them to the continued enjoyment of
their Slumbers while we turned out into
the woods continuing our course but not
traveling the roads
sometime after this a raid was planned
to cross the enemy's line and attack a
party of Haymakers who were encamped on
the Prairie north of the verdugri river
under protection of a Detachment of
soldiers from Fort Gibson it seemed to
be the policy of the military
authorities to use our Indian Brigade
not so much for service outside of the
Indian Territory as a menace to the
enemy's Southern Line we were constantly
watching for weak places or
insufficiently protected interests where
we might run in deliver a damaging blow
and fly quickly to the cover of our base
which in the later years of the war was
in the Choctaw Nation it was a kind of
warfare that was suited to the Indian
character and in carrying out the policy
we continually attracted the notice of
the enemy to ourselves thus keeping him
from concentrating with others of his
forces and aiding in giving effective
battle to some of our larger armies
which had already all the enemy that
they would care to deal with but now it
appeared that the choctaws none of whom
were with us in this raid had the
reputation with the enemy of being
heartless and of never sparing the life
of any enemy that came into their power
this was untrue but nevertheless
confidently believed by the enemy when
some of our soldiers made the Hideous
yells and charged the enemies left they
were mistaken for the deadly Choctaw for
as the enemy thought who but he could
utter such blood curdling noises they
reasoned that to yield their position
and trust a flight for safety would mean
their certain capture and Massacre on
the Prairies adjoining their camps by
these notorious and bloodthirsty
choctaws the only alternative being that
of remaining where they were and fight
it out the latter alternative they
adopted and those who were giving way to
flight returned and put up such a stiff
resistance that we were after a while
forced to reconsider our plans and give
up the fight
in this case the entire number of men
volunteering to engage in the raid did
not I think exceed 300. major Howland of
one of the Cherokee regiments was placed
in command and in this number of Raiders
there were Cherokee and Creeks from both
of the creek regiments I was of the
number with a few men from my immediate
company I remember that my cousin
Valentine n mcanally elsewhere mentioned
as being a month older than myself who
was a member of my company was with me
on this occasion
The Raid so far was regarded by the men
as evidently successful although the
cost of one life and a painful wound
the man had captured and appropriated
many of the various articles of value
from the camps of the enemy when they
charged them now as they were on their
return they crossed the river and being
tired and anxious to examine and see
more closely the booty they had each
taken they halted on the south banks of
the river where the Bluffs were high and
still
the boys were much pleased many of them
with their halls and were busily engaged
in showing each other their goods and
trading swapping and buying them from
one another in high Glee going up out of
the Bluffs to the top I dismounted and
with my Bridal reins in my hands
followed my horse around while he was
picking the grass which was very good
here and awaited orders to March
before such order was given however and
while the trade was brisk upon and below
the Bluffs the enemy whom we had
ransacked and dispersed having rallied
got together in considerable Force crept
up through the bottoms on the opposite
side and Delta sir volley from the thick
brush the stream only being about 50
yards wide here which created a panic in
our trade and dire consternation among
the Traders men who had dropped their
Bridal Reigns giving their horses full
Liberty to graze on the grass at will
were now running to and fro calling to
others to catch their horses for them
the horses when approached by frightened
men would in turn become frightened at
the unusual actions of their masters and
Scamper away which but for its
seriousness would have been in the
highest degree laughable we then
discovered that our commanding officer
major Howland was not with us there were
those who declared that the officer was
wounded by the enemy's first volley
Captain Sam Gunter of the Cherokees
would probably be next in command and
indeed was already rallying the men and
apparently waiting to get them into some
sort of shape for resistance or attack
of the enemy what to do was the question
that was uppermost to us
we held a council of War as it may be
called on Horseback when Captain Gunter
declared that if we could get a
sufficient number of men to follow him
he would attack the enemy our men
however exhibited no mind for engaging
in his proposed Enterprise I told the
captain for one I would follow him being
Burgess said that he would also go and
while there may have been others who
profit their services I do not recall
any
while we were talking Captain Gunter
decided that he would not make the
Venture as he said he himself was
wounded and in no proper condition for
leading a fight the captain however
could hardly have been called wounded as
what he designated as a wound as I
narrow call was only this one of the
enemy's bullets had struck the large
brass Army Buckle or clasp that fastened
his leather belt in front and without
going through it had reddened and
bruised his skin and probably Jarred him
considerably at the moment of impact
this was all
with this decision we as I must say
ignominiously left the field and our
commander without any effort toward
determining his fate or rendering him
any assistance a Detachment was sent out
in two days afterwards who found him
making his way back to camps over the
route traveling by his command and
brought him safely to camp
a short time after this I think it was a
new Commander came into our wing of the
theater of war and did some very
creditable work this was a general
Richard M Gano who before long in this
department received information of a
valuable train of wagons belonging to
the enemy and all loaded with supplies
for the post of Fort Gibson which was
moving down from Fort Scott Kansas he
determined to go after and meet these
people and if possible take them in
after several days of preparation some 2
000 men as I believe consisting of
creeks Seminoles Cherokees and Texans
with a battery of four pieces of
artillery were gotten in Readiness for
the Expedition I joined this Expedition
it having become my rule and purpose to
take part in all proposed raids against
the enemy it is perhaps right to explain
here that such inclinations did not
necessarily signify bravery courage or
desire in me for recklessly quoting and
facing danger as I found some of my
associates interpreted it but rather the
dominating influence of the somewhat
commonplace thirst for excitement and
desire for Action characteristic more or
less of all young people
from here we now moved on after bigger
game in two days thereafter as I now
recall we reach the encampment of the
enemy early in the morning the fires of
which we could clearly see for quite a
considerable distance before we were
sufficiently near to offer them battle
arriving however in Easy reach and it
being yet dark we formed an order of
battle and stood awaiting the light of
day when we could see how to meet and
dispute the men of which we had come so
far to see
while we were quietly awaiting the light
it appeared quite clear from the
boisterous and careless Talk of the
enemy which we could plainly hear that
there had been some drinking and that at
least some of the men were now under the
influence of drink
some of them called at us what are you
doing here what do you want some of our
men answered we are after you and your
mule teams and wagons presently one of
the enemy who evidently was drunk after
heaping upon a small manner of vile
epithets and curses started over our way
never ceasing his curses as he came he
came as I recall in such a way as to
reach the south end of our line as we
stood and presently one of the men
called to him halt
he appeared to pay no heed to the
challenge but continued his Advance when
we heard again the call to Halt this did
not check his movements so the third and
last challenge was made and within a few
moments a shot then another
and all was quiet
it was now light enough for us to see
what we should do and the order coming
to us to fire our men obeyed with
alacrity in spirit and things certainly
now began to appear decidedly war-like
before resuming and while waiting in
line for further orders some members of
my company having great faith in certain
Indian War medicine said to afford
protection against the casualties of
battle reduce the medicine Talisman or
whatever the article was I never saw it
and distributed it to those who decide
its protection which they proceeded to
use by rubbing it on and about the
clothing of the body and limbs as
thoroughly as they could within the
limited time they had for taking the
treatment
my first lieutenant superfe fixico
Thomas Benton as he was called in
English I distinctly recall offered to
supply me with a treatment saying aren't
you going to use this I declined his
Prophet kindness It's still being in me
to prove to these men that I was willing
to risk myself in the presence of danger
under the impulses of my innate courage
without resorting to the supposed
protection afforded by medicines or
talismans and proved to them that I
could meet the risks as Cooley as the
bravest soldier under me and was not the
man to shirk danger as some at one time
seemed to think I was
I'd loudly encouraged and cheered my men
from the first speaking always in Indian
until my voice gave way unto the
continued strain and was now only a
whisper and could scarcely be heard at
all Pleasant Porter always told me
afterwards that being with the charge
when the stockades were taken he looked
about him and saw not a single Creek
besides himself when there had been so
many on the firing line in the battle
proper he was just experiencing a
feeling of regret that the Creeks did
not have greater representation in this
crowning Act of actual Victory when
looking over a few steps from where he
stood he saw me the only other Creek and
felt an experience of relief it was a
sort of feeling as if the honor of the
creeks and this engagement in which we
were victorious had been sufficiently
Vindicated
one evening when the men had been some
hours reeling off to each other Yarns
funny and otherwise and conversation was
lagging I recall distinctly how Jackson
moon our way Rose from where he'd been
sitting starting to go to the fire to
light his pipe he remarked when under
our former Captain we made loud
complaints of his lack of courage to
lead us to battle we charged he was
cowardly I'm sure we have nothing to
complain of now
the former Captain was an old man and
really not a man for action and least of
all military action but he was put in
the office because he was old and was
regarded as one of the wise men of the
Eufaula town of Indians much had been
said in complaint against his inactivity
and this remark was meant for a
compliment to me and was so understood
by all
I never for a moment expected such a
compliment as Indians rarely ever say
things complementary to a person in his
presence this was therefore all the more
gratifying to me as proving that I'd
fully succeeded in satisfying my friends
and my enemies if I had any that I could
and would willingly go was far toward
meeting a dangerous proposition as any
other of my age and experience
I however have sometimes doubted whether
I was entitled to any credit for what
others regarded as courage in me for the
reasons that at the time I was but a boy
I probably did not fully appreciate the
dangers around me I don't think I did
the Brave and courageous man in my
present more mature judgment is he who
in his normal mental condition clearly
sees as he believes imminent danger and
even probable death before him and yet
without shrinking coldly faces and goes
into it
of course as he believes it is his duty
to do so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]